uh so how's everybody feeling it's super
early
super early for you guys now it's super
out it's super early for us i believe
meg's in the middle of the afternoon is
that right max everybody looks like
somebody had lunch and two glasses of
champagne guys i'm feeling great
a couple glasses of champagne how's that
jet lag doing are you are you already
like adjusted it takes me about two
three weeks to get adjusted when i go
here
i swear to god
that's hard i'm still not adjusted to
toronto and i've been here for almost
three weeks
but that's three hours that's a mental
thing i'm exaggerating yeah yeah um uh
rob is the sun up at your house because
like the sun's like just coming up in my
house and
yeah i i gotta have this like super
harsh overhead lighting you look well
lit i've been doing zoom since 2020 so i
have uh lighting set up well it's not
really a chicken night
because you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] dude
[Laughter]
i mean it's just a light you got a
lighting set up
[Laughter]
let's have a look
oh look at that beauty ring lights
yeah good for you
i mean
is it 20 is it what year is it we are
two years into this [ __ ] thing
we've been haven't you guys been doing
zooms recorded zooms for years
not only not only have i been doing all
these recorded zooms and stuff but you
know i've done enough stuff now where
anytime i have to shoot something or
film something on my laptop they just
send me equipment wait so you got a ring
light going too glenn not not right now
no i'm because i'm not at my house but i
mean at my house i've got all kinds of
like podcasting and and like
you know filming things on my computer
equipment that people have sent me and
then nobody ever comes to pick it up
it's good to have because your lighting
looks good i think i feel like i look a
little blasted out i look blasted out
down a little bit i think so you don't
see i get shadowy because it's over the
overhead light nobody cares
yeah the listener is just definitely not
having fun with this
what's this episode gonna be we got
something what are we doing here what
are we doing what are we doing here
we've got a wild idea yeah so i thought
i'd make a little game for you guys to
play because we're all spread out well
you certainly are in many different
places well now charlie you're back in
la so i guess just glenn's apart but i
wanted to um play a little version of
the newlywed game for you guys so that
you could remember that despite being
far apart you're actually very close
because of your 20 plus years of
friendship
[Music]
you know what we're far apart but
they're always in my heart
oh yeah hey [ __ ] you guys
totally yeah all right that's what's in
my heart that's what's in my heart yeah
so the way this is gonna work is that
i'm gonna ask you guys questions about
each other
and there'll be three sections one for
rob charlie and glenn i'm actually four
because then i'm going to
have a special lightning round at the
end and basically um you're going to
write your answers on these dry erase
boards that you should have in front of
you
and uh we're gonna take points and see
who wins who knows the most about their
um
fellow friends i mean i can already tell
you right now who's gonna win this game
it's definitely gonna be rob
i don't think i don't think so i i we've
already brought this up that charlie
keeps thinking that his memory is
terrible and then he keeps remembering
every single thing that we pose to him
so i think i think it's true i do feel
like i got a chance but i also feel like
rob you have
more of a
a mind that like studies a person you
know what i mean like where like you'll
pick up on a detail about me i'm
interested in you guys more than you're
interested in me yeah yeah yeah yeah a
little totally a little too
okay okay take it easy dial it down
actually so if i'm doing a section about
rob and your answers agree with what rob
is written down then you get a point
but rob if you like either of their
answers better than the one you've
written down you can choose to award
them half a point
because they're kind of subjective
answers so right right so this isn't
this isn't yeah this isn't like
background or factual this is this is
these are all what i think they're gonna
see i i yeah right i guess
i don't get it i don't get it at all
have you ever seen the newlywed game
it's been a very long time since i've
seen that game and i have to admit i was
getting hot
because i turned the heat on this
morning because it was cold and all i
could think about was like should i get
up do i get up and turn the heat off
right in the middle of the podcast like
do i do that and then i realized i
missed your entire explanation and i
haven't seen the newlywed game since i
was six years old
i mean
you pick up like a pack of cards or
whatever maybe some people have a mind
that they can sit and look at all those
instructions be like i get it let's go
i i'm like let's just play around and
yeah you guys figured out one round
you're like i got it okay yeah
yeah but the point is these are
subjective this this is not this is not
like trivia or or memory based this is
all more more about how do i believe
you're going to feel about something and
vice versa oh good okay okay
okay okay it's more eq than it is iq
right meg
yes that's correct eq what's eq
don't worry about it look it up your
emotional uh
quotient i don't know what you mean
that tells you a lot about my iq that's
your egg question i don't even know the
cure it's your quotient how many
questions my egg quotient my quotient is
excellent let's go oh
what the dad jokes you
buddy it's six you've been messing with
heat charlie and i just woke up it's six
o'clock in the morning by the way it's
shots on goal pal i got about i got
about [ __ ] eight jokes in this
podcast already all right let's get
going let's warm up buddy because the
audience wants to laugh glenn okay
they want to hear us complain about our
[ __ ] jet lag
and how warm it is in our gorgeous hotel
room it's so warm it's too warm in here
guys
megan's get this game on the rails
[Music]
um okay well we'll start with glenn's
since he doesn't know what's going on
that'll make it the easiest
the first question is what makes glenn
the most angry
uh just in general
yeah
oh
okay oh well i got it i know
charlie's ready to rock
you see that's amazing how there's so
much
that there's so much but uh but you went
for you just went for one rob whenever
you're ready
okay okay charlie show us your answer
okay i wrote
uh chewing loud oh
yeah okay
chewing chewing loud loud chewers you
know smacky foods i i see that i hear
that but i'll say that that's just one
thing
i think i think glenn looks uh when
things when things just don't work
when things that are supposed to work oh
sure yes things are supposed to work
don't work yeah that's a big one like
like just stuff technology thing just
stuff that's not working there's an
injustice to that
yeah okay one uh listen guys i mean
you're totally both of your it's not
what i wrote but it's 100 you're 100
correct in that those things make me
angry the difficult thing i think about
this is that so many things make me
angry so i wrote down
uh
a sort of a broader category which would
encompass what you wrote charlie can i
have a one second guess i won't write it
but just just to say yes did you write
the word life
wait i think i know you did i think i
know what you did i think i know what
you did yeah go for it you wrote you
wrote peep is having to do with people
not giving a [ __ ]
there's an injustice
you're one you are you you you didn't
say it the way i said it but i think
what you're saying is what i is i think
what you mean is what i meant when i
wrote what i wrote um yeah what'd you
write
lack of awareness
oh sure yeah yeah yeah i think charlie
should get a point for that i get the
point for the loud chewing well i think
it's up to glenn well what makes them
more crazy that things not working or uh
someone smacking their food while eating
um
charlie's answer is a part uh is a is a
more specific version of what i wrote
right so people's lack of awareness of
i was going to write a whole thing but
i was like i don't think it's supposed
to be this long
people's lack of awareness and they're
smacky smacking their food is the same
thing where the technology has nothing
to do with people that's compute that's
uh technology's lack of awareness of
what you wanted to do of what i needed
to do yes
my full answer would have been people's
lack of awareness of how their actions
affect other people that's that's the
thing that makes me the most angry
that's the broad category of like the
thing that makes me the most angry
um and
it is it seems like a half a half a
point to charlie seems very fair oh a
half a point okay okay let's see yeah we
can do we can do whatever we want
is fine i don't know i like the point i
i'm going to award charlie half a point
for that then
i think that's good the next question is
glenn says 90 of the time he eats
healthy and 10 of the time he eats
whatever the [ __ ] he wants it's a 10 day
so what is glenn eating
okay
i have a i have a thought
this was a tough one even for me
honestly all right this time rob why
don't you go first
this is a tough one but yeah this is a
tough one
because the man likes food the man the
man eats food amanda you you eat
you eat what you want generally what i
see um so i think if you're gonna
splurge what i've seen you do in the
past
is to just get a straight because you
don't eat as much red you don't eat red
meat you went for a long period of not
eating red meat for a while um i think
if you splurge you're going to get just
a just like just a hamburger and french
fries
this is really interesting
this is really interesting you want to
know what i wrote rob
a burger with french fries but never a
coke
never a soda never a soda just for one
little specific
so he's he's gonna get the regular fries
he's not gonna drink a cup of sugar on
top okay so here's the thing here's the
thing i think you guys should both get a
point for this because that's what i was
literally writing when i scratched it
out
and i actually think that your answer is
more right than mine
yeah like because mine i think mine is a
little bit more
it's like this is this is i gravitate
towards this but like if i'm really
going for it and that was the question
that's exactly right i would i would be
like a cheeseburger with the works
you know
and uh and and some fries so and you're
right and no soda and i am i'm almost
tempted to give charlie an extra half a
point there for the no soda thing by the
way this is what i wrote
i wrote a turkey sandwich with with
extra mayo and fries
but
uh but that just seems too healthy i
mean even that even the extra mayo kind
of puts it over the top but
you know i think you guys are right all
right burger and fries all right let's
move on jesus christ i'll award a point
for both of them
um yeah okay okay the next question is
glenn is going to star in guns actually
a big budget action movie about a man
whose father is tragically murdered
causing him to go on an epic rampage
what actor is glenn casting to play his
father
done and done got it
meaning that he has a choice or this is
this is like a realistic like no no he
has the choice of who is going to the
choice of all actors yes all actors now
is this what's the sorry what is the
tone of this movie is it is it a is it a
an action comedy is it or just a
straight like no it's a straight action
get carter type of thing yeah
all right and your father is in action
has to be an action actor no because he
dies at the beginning of the movie so
he's not needing to do a lot of action
it's just a great actor okay oh i'm
tempted to do a joke here but i also
want the point
yeah why don't you put the joke at the
bottom
uh
the joke he's going to put is himself
aged up
no it wasn't but i wish that i was oh
god yeah myself me aged well that's
that's right
that was yes i know i'd be great all
right
charlie why don't you show us first okay
i i wrote
he's gonna go with gary oldman uh
gary oldman is you know who's going to
go who's available but if you want
accuracy it's got to be lindsey
buckingham okay
i mean that's just a grand slam if we're
going purely on looks i forgot about
that just the other day we were having
we were talking on the podcast about
like doppelgangers and i forgot that
that's one that i get all the time like
this is funny i see these pictures of
him now and he does
it's more like he has a dennis reynolds
vibe than he has a glenbard you know
what i mean like
something about it his hair is always
hot this is how much his hair is very
high how much charlie and i know and
love glenn i said the same thing and
aged up gary oldman because he can do
anything and be any age
well you guys this was a tough one uh
amazing that you both wrote gary oldman
one of my favorite actors of all time i
did not even think of gary oldman i
still stand by uh my actual choice
brendan gleason no that doesn't make
sense no it's not like he's even like
one of my favorite actors although he is
a phenomenal actor and i absolutely love
him in things i don't know why this is
who i this is who i want
christopher walken christopher
your brain sometimes it's just wrong
interesting it's just wrong it's
terrible casting yeah and you're wrong
it's actually not the answer the answer
is gary oldman i believe we know you
better yeah you don't know your own mind
okay
well i think that you my son
who
uh
comes in the room
i don't know man
everyone does walk in no one wants to
hear a walking like if you guys see like
christopher walken in uh
my boy wow
it was me
dad
sure um okay sorry uh you guys you guys
do know me very well uh gary oldman's
one of my favorite actors uh uh and uh
uh uh i mean again it's not what i wrote
but i don't know how you ever why did
you pick christopher walker i don't
because i was i don't know for some
reason his performances
he was the first [ __ ] person that
popped into my head and i wrote it down
that's not overthinking it no points
awarded i was thinking of his
performance in seven psychopaths uh
which
is just like so phenomenal so good
have you guys seen that movie
please tell me you've seen seven
psychopaths yeah i watched it with you
years ago oh god it's so good or maybe
i've seen it i don't know it's so good
it's one of those movies you can watch
like 15 000 times it's it's fantastic
watch it again if you haven't seen it
okay here's a question that's not
subjective what was glenn's starter car
as in his first car he ever had the
actual
trip in real life
yes in real life what was his starter
car glenn this is just a question would
this have been in high school or did it
was your first car since we've known you
uh i mean i she's i i think you're
talking about my very first car right
yeah yeah you had you had you had a car
and then you had another car
the car that you brought out here was
different than your very first car yeah
you guys never met my first car but no
but i think i know i think i know what
it is
okay
uh let's start with rob on this one
i believe your first car when you were
in high school was a volvo
it was a volvo wow do you happen which
is different than the one you came out i
mean that's that's that's that's uh um
very difficult but it just for extra
points maybe if you can get the year the
year of the volvo it was an 85 i'm
jumping in for a point here there's an
85 volvo um it was my dad's it was my
dad it's the first car my dad ever
bought for himself that's a clue yeah
yeah wow a 76 volvo i'm gonna say it's a
1981 volvo well you guys think it took
my dad that long to buy a car
okay 76. i said 76. uh i'll just like
you know i wrote a 1999 acura a 1999
acura legend okay that's a great that's
a great gift that's a great guess
because very good answer yeah that's
very good answer it was a 19 very much
that was the car that i got my senior
that i uh uh was able to split with my
parents my senior year of high school it
was a 1990 acura legend but
very good i got that pretty damn good
pretty damn good um however rob gets the
point it is a volvo it was a
1966 volvo
uh people
his nickname was pearl jam was pearl
jack jam that's cute
just because it was pearl white it's
cool
man it was so so great we kept it for a
long time i wish we still had it i wish
i could restore it i would well done rob
did you remember that he had discussed
having a volvo at one point in time in
his life yes
okay well then yeah yeah i wasn't just a
guest that was you remembering yeah i'm
going to give a point to rob on that one
um if glenn had to speak in a different
accent for the rest of his life which
accent would he pick
okay okay i feel like glenn's gonna have
an interesting answer here but she's not
which is not accurate what we're
expecting no it's not no it's not
okay charlie you wanna go first well my
first my first if i just went off my
first instinct it would have been like a
british accent but
i switched it because i thought
he's gonna get tired of people being
tired of that accent and thinking that
he's hoity toity he's gonna want to
sometimes just be able to go home and
just fit in and i went with a southern
accent he's just gonna slide into a
comfy southern accent just for
peace of mind i'm gonna say glenn
now if i weren't going to think about it
for a second i think he would want to do
because i've heard him do this many
times and it's very funny uh and i
believe he would want to do a german
accent what a german accent
rob i like your thinking because
sometimes glenn comes out with an answer
where you're like huh yeah he was going
he was going along the the lines of my
overthinking it and not giving the most
obvious yeah yeah yeah
your answer so we have kind of like
in the glory hole i remember you getting
really into that and he was just doing a
nondescript european accent well that's
and i'm a big fan of that by the way
just just like a european accent which
is just like kind of all of it i'm
guessing though you wrote a british
accent because of just the the beauty of
the sound and the flow and you and it
feels comfortable to do and and i'm i'm
guessing
[Music]
i have an affinity for that for it
because uh you know i lived there as a
kid and and i had a accent i had a
british accent as a little kid for a
short short period of time
and
i just love it there i love it well
that's the glen round
[Music]
[Applause]
we are supported by shopify hey you guys
ever think about starting a small
business together oh you're talking
about a little side hustle um what do
you have in mind
i don't know maybe something in retail
or e-commerce you know artisan scented
candles macrame wall art
i don't know you know that that whole it
all sounds pretty complicated right like
how how are we going to compete with
with big macrame right where are we
going to get in the the big macrame
industry is uh
that's a tight community can't get a
foothold in right how do you even start
where did we start well i'll tell you
what shopify gives entrepreneurs like
ourselves the resources once reserved
for only big businesses glenn i'm gonna
need you to go on about this a little
bit okay so all right i will so upstarts
startups and established businesses
alike can sell
everywhere um synchronize online and
in-person sales and gain insights as
they grow with detailed reporting of
conversion rates profit margins and
beyond now that's a lot of big words you
just said there glenn sorry sorry i'm a
smart guy yeah that's okay but what
about reaching customers online and
across like social networks you know
with an ever
growing suite of channel integrations
and apps like facebook instagram ted tic
tac pinterest and more you know there's
so much out there now i don't even know
what's out there yep a lot of big words
there too but uh yeah shopify provides
all that yeah shopify powers millions of
businesses from first sale to full scale
it's more than a store shopify grows
with you that's shopify.com
sunny go to shopify.com
sunny all lowercase for a free 14-day
trial and get full access to shopify's
entire suite of features grow your
business with shopify today go to
shopify.com
sunny right now
that's shopify.com
sunny
shopify.com
sunny
[Music]
we are supported by a zip recruiter
yeah okay say we're gonna run a
promotion for paddy's tuesday night is
ladies night at paddy's pub oh sure
great you know it's ladies night and we
we need to hire some people like
a cheese sample guy
yeah oh cheese is very classy uh ladies
love cheese well i mean who doesn't love
cheese right everybody loves cheese okay
so we need a cheese guy on the fly and
we'd want to hire the best person for
the job right like a sommelier for
cheese a real
cheese whiz ooh a cheese oh
okay a wizard of cheese cheese wizard
cheese that's why we'd use zip recruiter
and if you're hiring for your business
you should go to ziprecruiter.com sunny
right now to try ziprecruiter for free
guys ziprecruiters powerful technology
finds the best people with the right
skills and experience for your job and
presents them to you and then you can
personally invite your top choices to
apply for your job four out of five
employers who post on ziprecruiter get a
quality candidate within the first day
so in less than 24 hours paddy's pub
would have a cheese
expert it's daddy yeah yeah yeah so find
the right people for the job when you
try zip recruiter for free
at
zip
that's three people talking at once so
once again one at a time that's
ziprecruiter.com
ziprecruiter.com
ziprecruiter.com
slash sunny
uh guys we are supported by tommy john
by the way rob sorry you look really
cool today man
i don't know what it is
well thank you for notice that i'm
feeling i'm feeling rather cool today
have you had a haircut or a shave did
you get a little pre uh workout in
before the pod you look great no
no well thank you uh we started the
podcast very early today and um i i just
happened to be
wearing my my tommy john undies oh you
popped on some tommy john's okay that's
what it is it's and it's it's actually
emanating out of you and making your
whole thing cooler the the underwear
actually does keep me seven degrees
cooler than cotton
that is oddly specific well you want to
be cool you don't want to be overheated
right you want to be uh light and breezy
well if you want your underpants to be
anything you want them to be breathable
lightweight and with four times the
stretch of any competing brand because
you know you know i need the stretch you
guys both are very happy that i need a
stretch well you know you blow up you
get too big and then you you shrink down
you don't want to be constricted you
want to have room to grow uh guys listen
there is no risk because tommy john's
got you covered with their best pair
you'll ever wear or it's free
guarantee
okay well really i'm sold not just you
pal with over 17 million pairs sold i
think it's safe to say people are loving
tommy john i know i am so shop
tommyjohn.com
sunny right now for 20 off your first
order that's right get 20 off right now
if you go to tommyjohn.com
sunny tommyjohn.com
sunny the sunny is very important
tommyjohn.com
sunny otherwise meg does not eat see
sight for details
[Music]
all right here we go first question for
charlie charlie gets to play a round of
golf with any famous person living or
dead who does he choose oh
got it
i'm just gonna keep that one simple i'm
not gonna go nothing crazy here
i mean i haven't got a clue i haven't
got a clue
not a clue
playing golf with somebody okay uh rob's
written tiger woods
as his answer glenn do you wanna i mean
i thought glenn already conceded yeah
conceded
um
just give me one second here hold on
hold on hold on hold on hold on
no that's
god damn it i'm overthinking it i don't
know i can see okay england passed away
it was in fact tiger woods i mean if
you're going to get a round of golf with
anybody
with the person uh who is arguably the
best player ever to play the game um
[Music]
okay
good good answer rob good answer you
guys play golf together i know you're
very i know i know yeah you know that's
true we golf togethers and glenn doesn't
golf as much so
okay here's one that's not subjective
how old was charlie when he had his
first kiss
oh
[ __ ] wait i gotta think of that
wait wait how could you not know but
megan knows
because it's right on the cusp of two
ages but i i i i yeah i think i'm okay
okay okay wait i think i got it you can
write down two ages to give them more of
an i don't know
i'm pretty
short it's this one
okay i wrote down two two ages glenn you
want to go first
says 14 18
14. i know that's i know that's late but
uh charlie just strikes me as a little
bit of a late bloomer not that he
couldn't have been kissed but
good instincts but just that uh you were
the type you're the type of person to to
not go for the kiss unless you're
absolutely sure and i think that takes a
little bit of it
and because of that because of that i'm
going to go later i'm going to go later
not because he didn't have the
opportunity but because yeah
he he he's been very clear that he would
never go for the the kiss unless he knew
it was a definite which is a hard thing
to do
15 or younger so i believe he was 16 on
the cusp of 17. i i i was tempted to do
that i was tempted to go there and i was
like god that's almost insulting
i believe well don't worry about that
pal because i believe it was actually
17 or i might have even been 18. it was
not until my senior year of high school
my goodness um yeah i remember you i was
frustrated about it believe me um
now was this your first your first kiss
in general or like your first like kiss
kiss
uh both
yeah
yeah
um and then
i think
i think um
it was definitely my senior year so i
can't remember if i was 17 or i might
have been 18 which was adding to the
humiliation but uh
to my credit though
my high school for out throughout my
freshman and sophomore and most of my
junior year was an all-boys school so it
made it even harder why can't you kiss
boys you can but i didn't want to so
that's oh
you know that was that held back yeah
that held you back yeah not wanting to
use what made you not do it huh
that's a big part of it yeah yeah okay
um next question is the dj do i get a
half a point for that i i i think that's
well i said 16 on the cusp of 17 he said
seven seven kills
on the cusp of seventeen i think half at
least a half pointer okay i did say
seven for rob megan did you know
i didn't know no oh okay but this is how
the newlywed game works because they
don't know the answers you can provide
questions yeah oh yeah i could ask you
guys where's your favorite place to make
whoopee because that's pretty that's
always a good question
that was the big one
what's whoopee is that a sandwich
um
i believe it's sexual intercourse i
believe it's a she's a view on the host
yeah she's the host
i was like wait what is the view in the
house what the [ __ ] am i talking about
how about this one um charlie is having
a midlife crisis what does he buy for
himself oh i know exactly what this is i
know i know this yeah yeah yeah
okay i'm pretty sure i got this one
glenn you wanna you wanna show first
a classic car
okay
classic sports car
yeah oh i almost sports car yeah yeah i
i called it vintage instead of classic
but a vintage car maybe i'm thinking
like a 60s ferrari convertible because
it's a crisis i'm really i'm spending
too much money right i'm like
overspending it's like a two million
dollar car sometimes hi one point each
guys great job yeah okay trying to have
midlife crisis for a while now you sure
have you been talking about having a
midlife crisis in that regard for quite
a bit
i'm going to get a good vintage car pull
the trigger on that you gotta pull the
trigger on that mid-life crisis man what
is charlie the most proud of and i'm
gonna say that his wife and child are
exempt from this
oh
i'm not sure i know the answer to that
um
i know i know the answer i i mean i
think i i think i i think i know the
answer i think i'm right okay rob
on this one robbie
sonny sonny
glenn
always sunny always funny okay
charlie
they're horrible bosses
[Laughter]
sunny babies
would that have been the same for you
guys 100
100 without a doubt nice
unquestionably money is the best
everything else is great but sunny's the
best
it's just very very special okay one
more and then i think that makes this
even to the amount we did for glenn um
i'm easy these guys know these guys know
me it's like this
it's no mystery what movie would charlie
most like to have written and starred in
and this could be from any era
okay
this is pretty easy too
i wouldn't say that this was easy but
it's the first thing that popped into my
mind and i don't think you'll say i'm
wrong charlie but you might have one
that's
no
i think this is right
i want easy first instinct i mean
there's a million of them that i wish i
wrote and started okay i think i think i
got it okay glenn you want to go first
the big lebowski okay rob good one rob
said dog day afternoon
oh wow you know what it was it was
between the two but i went with lebowski
just uh
just for the comedy of it but dog
honestly uh
my second instinct was dog day afternoon
my first was but you wrote lebowski you
wrote about i did i did because i'm
going to say yeah i'm going to say it's
not right
no no no it's it's it's right i think i
i watch lebowski more than i have
watched dog day afternoon it would be a
very different movie
you know obviously uh
jeff bridges
performance in that is absolutely
amazing but like i would like to see
that movie with you in it i think you'd
be amazing dude i would like to make my
own lebowski at some point you know
you're working on it i'd rather see you
in dog day afternoon if i'm being honest
in fact i'd rather see you and dog day
afternoon and glenn i'd like to see you
in the big lebowski oh god i would love
but maybe i want you playing tutorials
part though what about me and glenn and
dog day afternoon
oh okay yeah
glenn and i are robbing the bank
together am i are you pacino and i'm
kazel or what are we doing yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's cool maybe we do like a
cat like cat cat day cat day
you know
mid lunch you know
lunch or cat day mid lunch i'd see that
movie
okay we're moving on to rob guys you
ready see how much you know rob
okay the first question is
caitlyn and the kids are out of town how
is rob spending his evening
his evening uh
ah that's a joke answer [ __ ] all right
um well
if you're gonna go if you're gonna go
base just pass just pass space it's not
bass okay uh okay hold on
i'm ready
all right i'm gonna give my my my first
answer is a joke and my second answer is
my real answer my first answer which i
wanted to do as a joke i was going to
write working
i wrote starting a new business
that's so sad because i wrote that and
then stopped because i was like oh
that's so sad rob i know you have a a
kickback side i wrote
drinking in manhattan watching the
eagles as if as if the eagles are an
option but i wrote a manhattan and a
movie
oh my god you guys know me so well
because i literally started writing
working and then was like that's so sad
i don't want to do that and then i wrote
drinking whiskey and watching and then i
stopped because i was like am i watching
like
i know that yeah i know the eagles are
specific yeah you're watching something
whatever that's really i think that's a
point to both give a point to point
yeah i think you should get two points
because you got bo you got both of them
we got but we actually i kind of agree
with right i didn't want to write
working because it was so sad all right
two points guys
yeah yeah but your first instinct would
be like okay man i gotta come up with
something i have some time to focus and
the kids aren't here and
to bother me so i could really dig in on
some work here and then it would be like
what has no one done yet like what how
can what's elon musk done i could
probably do what he does
and then and then realize i'm too stupid
to do anything like that it's the dumber
version of making that much money what's
like the dumb version
and i'm like what's the thing that i
could do as a dumb guy
no but but listen i actually understand
the appeal of that like i i have there
is something kind of
really nice about
sitting down with a glass of whiskey or
a glass of wine or whatever and getting
some work done considering
that i would say
you know not not everything we do is fun
but i actually really enjoy most of the
work that i do yeah for as much as it
frustrates me so it's actually fun
sometimes to to work yeah during
non-work hours with a cocktail in your
hand i think i probably could even
squeeze another point out of this
because the real answer is masturbating
well right that was the basis that was
the base answer though
all three things are correct all three
he's getting all three in for the night
but wait a second what you've just
described you've just described
what every man on the planet in fact
probably any humans on the planet would
do if their if their families are not
around masturbate work and then
enjoy a cocktail and watch tv i mean
that's i think many would not work many
would not work or go the work most would
be like wait a second i don't have to
work i'm just going to go straight to
the masturbation yeah and the boom is in
the movie
look two out of three in no particular
order for two out of three the
masturbation comes first but beat it
drink it watch it
here's a question though here's a
question would you would you
make the manhattan and drink the
manhattan while masturbating and then
make another manhattan for the movie or
would you masturbate just to get it out
of the way just to get the demons out
and then make the manhattan and go watch
what here's what i'd say i don't usually
work at night what i would probably do
is i would wake up i do what i do now
which is wake up really early before
anybody's awake then work then i'm not
talking about them well then at night i
would i would dr i would make i only
drink one manhattan every night a big
one but it's a big one but it's just one
i drink the one and then i watch the
movie
then [ __ ] 32 ounce man yeah
it's a big gulp yeah and then when
that's over i turned whatever that show
or movie was was and then i then i would
then i would
complete my oh at the end of the evening
oh yeah i'd get it out of the way i
usually get it out of the way i'm like i
gotta get this out of me i need to get
this out of me
there's something to look forward to
something like oh
oh good for you delayed gratification
what time did you wake up this morning
did you wake up uh shortly before the
podcast no i got up at like 5 15. good
for you god bless um i i i do by the way
can we not move past the fact that
in order to be able to tell yourself
that you only have one drink a night
you d you basically make like twice the
size of a normal manhattan maybe three
times i'll take a picture of it and put
it on the podcast yeah no i take it to
the brim the next question about rob is
what was rob's first job
oh his first job very first job
rob this is in high school at some point
i'm assuming right or like no this
wasn't grade school increasingly oh you
wait you got to do something you got
like a paycheck for i i did
well was it was a cash business
well okay i then i'll tell you what
there's two answers if you can get your
first job you can you can say that i'm
going classic here guys
okay there's there's two there's there's
there is two but i think that that's
fair meg and both of them are classic
very americana okay
paperclip
glenn says paperboy charlie
i wrote a altar boy load wipe down boy
altar boy
in parentheses wipes down the loads
like
robe de stainer
[Laughter]
i don't know i wasn't sure i wasn't sure
when i was like 11 or 12 and then i
pumped gas in high school oh i remember
that yes i remember you talking about
that you pumped gas my freshman year of
high school i pumped but the first but
you get a paycheck for being a
pay-per-view
yeah i can't remember if it was like a
shady cash business no i
i don't know if i was old enough to have
a job at 12. so they may have had a
really hey
yeah and it was one of those local
papers that nobody wanted they would
they would just like
appear on your doorstep and you just
take it and throw it in the garbage so
i'll give you glenn a point for that
um the next question is uh if rob gave a
ted talk what would the subject of it be
okay
i went non-joke
okay charlie what do you got
me too
i wrote show running and the business of
hollywood
all right just like basically like you
know and uh
an area of expertise
no one knows anything make your own
rules
oh that's interesting i like that glenn
oh that's
um i i said creative collaboration which
i think we should give charlie a point
for that
i think this is very rob
how about we both get a point for that
yeah well that that
those are the things that i've
learned and i think we all have learned
a version of that in in these are all
areas i don't know meg i think i think a
point each oh wow okay yeah i mean i do
think that uh this is something
you know that you discovered along the
way uh you know working on it's always
sunny and various other projects is that
like
you know the rules that people set in
place
are are are often arbitrary uh or don't
you know no longer apply and and the
people who are administering or you know
what's the word i'm looking for
enforcing the rules don't even really
understand what they're for or why
they're beneficial to the project or
whatever you know so what you discover
is that like your whole thing is to just
push through just do your thing just do
it just [ __ ] do it and don't worry i
mean i'm not talking about like rules
they're not laws i'm not talking about
laws and i'm not they're not i'm not
talking about how much how often have we
yeah how often have we over the course
of making this show really we've come up
against a
an idea or a structure or something that
was put in place long ago and then
enforced by people who don't understand
why they're enforcing it and then you
right if you just peel back and ask why
you realize that they don't know the
answer and then you realize oh there are
no
there there is no rule this is just
arbitrary
it's like there's no experts and the
so-called experts are really their
expertise is only just what oftentimes
what they're comfortable with
not failing at right so they're like
well we do this this way because we
won't fail but then you're like well but
yeah but but of course not and of course
not all the time there are lots of
experts in different fields and we have
to be able to recognize
which ones are the ones are to be
listened to and which ones are the ones
this is what i like about you rob if i
may uh you know you're not one to just
break the rules arbitrarily or because
you're not getting what you want you
will ask the question what is the
purpose of this rule and if the answer
satisfies you and it feels logical
then you'll follow the rule because
you're like that makes sense i i
shouldn't you know do x y and z because
what you just said makes sense you know
you will listen to reason it's just that
if the rules don't make any sense or if
the person explaining it can't explain
it because they don't even know what it
means and no one can explain it and no
one can make sense of it
then you're like no [ __ ] it then i'm not
doing it well let's do a ted talk let's
do a let's do a three-person ted talk
about this very thing yeah
it's a lot worse
it's a lot of work it sounds like a lot
of work
i'd rather be masturbating
yeah
yeah sure sure yeah
isn't a ted talk a form of masturbation
well let's be honest
yes absolutely self gratification people
named ted they're [ __ ] psyched
um okay the next question is what movie
is most likely to make rob cry oh okay
um
hmm
maybe after manhattan i know like what
the subject matter would be but i don't
i can't think of a
which movie that is um you could write
subject matter if it fits with the movie
he's written down i'll give you a point
for that i think i've got the general
category um but i'm not sure if i've got
the specific movie
all right glenn
what's it say what does that say
uh
pixar movie so
my first thought was because i you know
you really like those pixar movies i
thought maybe it would be a pixar movie
uh and then i just i don't know why
inside out was the one that popped
and i couldn't think of anything better
so i don't know i can't think of a movie
i just wrote
anything or the subject
matter is a dad and his sons you know
like that's kind of that's gonna cut you
to the quick like if it's a movie about
yeah i mean that i think okay so here's
what i wrote i wrote i wrote rocky
because it's the first thing that popped
into my head
but what i would say is that my make you
cry that movie makes you cry yeah rocky
makes me cry yeah
yeah if i think about it and talk about
it too much i'll probably start crying
so i'm not going to do that
[Laughter]
but field of dreams
is a pretty dream there you go yep so
that's a father-son
story that's
hard to deny you're definitely right
about the the whole father-son thing
anytime anytime like a
father-son thing happens i'm like i
can't handle it man it's like it's so
intense for me um but i would say in
terms of pixar movies anybody who
watches the first what
six minutes of up and doesn't cry oh my
god no you're 100
oh you're right you're right that
opening is so
mind-blowingly good i remember a moment
with you glenn where you said something
about we were having this conversation
you were like i'm not into animated
movies they don't really make me feel i
don't really care that much i don't know
that i can be emotionally invested and i
said did you see up and you said no and
i sat there and watched it with you i
was like
watching it
you cried you did you did
yeah
it's it's it's one of the best
things ever one of the best openings to
any movie ever yeah it's incredible it's
incredible how they make you care
full they make you care so much in such
a short period of time right at the
beginning i mean that's a
for anyone who
and anyone who understands filmmaking
knows how difficult that is to make
people feel something deeply
in in the first five minutes of watching
something is almost impossible yeah it's
almost impossible and then you're
emotionally invested in these characters
right from the go i mean that is so
difficult to do as a as a filmmaker mad
respect for the people who may up yeah
big ups mad response
[Music]
okay this is the last one for rob
rob has to give up either booze or sex
how does he kill himself sex rampage or
booze rampage
i mean
got it i i feel like i'm sad i sound
like such an alcoholic i drink one
manhattan tonight one big
one sex a night or does that
hold on one second did you write booze
guys can you write a movie called sex
rampage oh my god can i can i reframe
the can can i reframe the question for
from myself just like am i married
no no
oh
all right he's changed his answer all
right yeah that was very sweet of you to
to yeah to to very safely for your your
wife and children and you're
hypothetical very sick yeah i would
assume that
if i'm gonna if i'm gonna kill myself i
wanna do it with virtue
[Music]
okay so the speed round is basically
that i'm gonna ask you questions about
who is the most whatever amongst the
three of you and the consensus wins so
you write r c or g
and um and you can write yourself if you
feel like you're the person but whoever
gets two out of three uh wins and then
we give you the points for that so uh
the people who got it right so
all right here we go
who has the most speeding tickets
i see g g [ __ ] sorry g okay so you get
i'll get one point for that
who would survive the longest in a
zombie apocalypse
got robbed oh wow
the guys are in agreement i'll say rob
let's go
boys okay
who is the best at keeping a secret
oh
oh
i mean i think all three of us would be
yeah i would i would actually say i
would say all of us
all right well rob wins because he got
the consensus
i was i was i was writing i was going to
write rcg
but i guess we can't do that if you all
were to get chloroformed who'd have the
best chance of fighting it off
fighting like the person who's trying to
chloroform you fighting the person yeah
yeah who's trying to chloroform you off
yeah charlie you and i are thinking the
same
ready three two
yeah but rob's done all the the karate
[ __ ] and he lifts the weights and stuff
okay i would say that glenn glenn would
glenn would be the best that fighting
off the drug taking over his body i
think that's more what i was yeah i
would agree with that because he's
thought about it the most yes oh boy
yeah sure okay uh who makes the best
first impression
three two
one i think that's me uh
i don't know i don't know i don't i mean
speed round guys
that's that's that's i i feel like we
all three of us make a good first
impression if i may
all right this one well this one will
prove itself
who is the fastest writer
oh uh wait wait sorry do you mean typing
or do you mean like
yeah i guess oh i guess all things
considered who get scripts out the
fastest
three
who ruins the most takes by laughing or
breaking for those people who don't know
that's a tough one but
three two one
yeah
right right
i'm pretty bad i'm pretty good you or me
it could be it could have been that's
the taste i just went with my first
toss-up but i lost that was a toss-up
okay and then the last question is who
is the most competitive
[Applause]
oh i know we're all pretty damn
competitive we're all pretty competitive
i don't i don't know i don't i don't
know i don't know let's be honest let's
be honest here let's be totally honest
okay
go ahead write it down
okay
deep down inside
you write the first thing to say glenn i
already wrote it down based on glenn's
tone immediately i'm gonna wrote it down
immediately
okay fine you don't think you're the
more competitive yeah charlie
i think charlie by miles me
he did you wouldn't think that's
outwardly i know it's not an outward
it's not an outward show i would think
that i think that outwardly you would
think that it would be
you or i
yeah i think like deep down that's what
i thought you were implying
yeah i do i do think that charlie is
highly competitive it's just that he
doesn't have any he doesn't have like
the outward sort of like demeanor of
like a highly competitive point and
you're also not like you're not you're
not like i think often like hi super
competitive dudes are often like have
the alpha male thing and you're and
it depends on the thing in life right
like
if it's like us trying to make a
great tv show versus other tv shows out
there yeah i have a competitive streak
right if it's like uh you know playing
around in golf
ah i'm playing a win you know like i'm
usually playing to play as good as i can
you're collaborating you're
collaborative you're collaborative and
you're
you know it's not it's not like it's not
it's like it's it's not like it's all
about winning but when it is about
winning
yeah i'd say you're the most competitive
well okay we're about to find out who
won this game how how are you feeling
about that are you do you want to win i
tell you what i did have a when this was
getting going we were talking about
points and the first round when i only
got a half point it did spike that
little like competitor
thing in me where i was like oh [ __ ] i
don't get a [ __ ] half point and then
i let it go right so i do i do and then
i was writing you know low jokes and
stuff but
but i do have that thing where it's just
like yeah like if it's a competition if
someone has like laid down the rules and
i think that just comes from like
doing so much competing as a kid like
always
all i did with my kids my buddies was
playing some kind of sports game so much
so like
got hardwired i don't know but you
probably i mean i i i i feel like you
feel like a little bit of an underdog or
or did as a kid
maybe and and and i don't think i do
anymore but my guess is that you you
probably deep down like knew that you
were capable of more than people gave
you credit for or or thought you were
capable of
and so there was this desire to prove it
you know what i mean maybe yeah yeah i
mean i think all three of us can be
pretty competitive if oh without sparked
oh we all have chips on our shoulders
and are looking to prove something to
somebody oh yeah i think most people are
absolutely yeah come on
all right so meg did you count
it up i did tally it up and
according to my calculations we have
rob with 10 and a half points
glenn's got 13 points
and charlie has 13 and a half points
[ __ ] this game
[ __ ] that
that's [ __ ] [ __ ] this
you know i thought i didn't care but
then when you started talking about the
points i felt care in my body you know i
felt like there it is i want the most
points i want the cookie
you know
i give me the cookie give me this send
you all cookies i want the trophy i want
megan to think that i have more points
you want her to think that yeah yeah
yeah
we've talked about this before but i've
uh and this is maybe for a different
podcast but i've never beat charlie and
golf ever ever
yeah but that's not totally fair because
i started playing way before you uh but
we've played a hundred times if not more
i'm um better than you
yeah yeah that's what he's saying that's
what rob says i know oh that's what i'm
saying it gnaws at me
yeah i know it's kind of fun um
you just gotta put a little more work
into it and a little less time into
things that matter like
work and your family you know a little
more time into just
banging a ball around the field yeah
he's right rob he's just on the
dedication um all right guys well this
has been fun yeah uh uh
i love you man
man do i love you guys meg i love you
too
oh true thanks i love you guys too
thanks man back at you guys cut that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]